[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau rendez vous de dimanche en
politique
difficile d'échapper au grand débat au
grand déballage de ce qui ne va pas dans
notre pays et dans notre région rurale
nous avons décidé de nous intéresser un
sujet qui revient souvent l'emploi loin
des villes peut-on encore vivre et
travailler au pays
en reprenant un slogan bien connu des
années 70 pour en débattre sur ce
plateau mahfoud aomar bonjour bonjour
vous êtes président des maires de
l'yonne maire vous même de valve
ravillon une nouvelle commune qu'est née
de la fusion c'est sûr commune et n'y en
a pas tant
fabien bazin bonjour bonjour maire de
lormes dans le morvan l'orme c'est un
peu un laboratoire de la ruralité passe
comme ça qu'on dit on va en parler et
eric michoux bonjour vous êtes maire
d'epervans saône et loire vous êtes chef
d'entreprise et vous avez été il ya un
certain nombre d'années président du
medef de saône et loire ce qui nous
intéresse aussi sur le sujet du jour
je parlais en ouverture du climat actuel
alors à votre échelle de mer dans vos
communes sur le terrain fabien bazin est
ce que le sujet dont on parle
aujourd'hui fait partie du climat cette
préoccupation de ne pas trouver d'emploi
de ne pas retrouver si on le perd de se
dire il n'y a pas assez d'entreprises
n'y a pas assez d'emplois là où je vis
avec très clairement mais c'est une
préoccupation sur l'ensemble du
territoire national depuis des dizaines
d'années des dizaines d'années
maintenant on voit bien que la france
est accroché à ceux se ses 9 % ce taux
de chômage qui ne couvre d'ailleurs pas
tout puisque les petits boulots les
travaux le travail à temps partiel c'est
aussi une problématique pour bon nombre
de nos concitoyens nous regarde le
niveau de salaire de revenus
nada domicile ou d'une ash dans un
hôpital dans une maison de retraite
c'est un scandale national
comment ces gens peuvent-ils vivre
décemment avec 1200 euros et un dos
brisé à 40 sur les zones rurales note
particulière louis aussi alors le taux
de chômage dans les zones rouges
installés hier que vous êtes combien le
chômage c'est quoi alors c'est plutôt un
point un point et demi de moins que le
taux que le taux national
mais je pense qu'il faut pas s'arrêter à
ces a cessé ses opérations comptables et
regarder véritablement dans le dans le
détail on peut pas comparer aujourd'hui
une métropole est une petite ville ou un
village rural on est on ne vit pas dans
les mêmes conditions que la vie n'est
pas le même notamment est ce qu'on
constate malgré tout et paradoxalement
c'est plutôt un regain d'activité dans
nos dans nos territoires si je prends
l'exemple de l'orme
en deux ans il ya dix huit activités
nouvelles ou de reprises qui ont pu voir
le jour c'est pas rien sur une dizaine
d'années le canton de lormes ses 102
emplois actifs de plus qu'il ya dix ans
irait à l'encontre de l'idée générale
qu'on entend en ce moment et ces
dernières semaines sur les zones rurales
abandonné et est en difficulté mais on
va on va essayer de comprendre pourquoi
pourquoi il ya ce décalage aussi mahfoud
a marre le quand vous entendez fabien
bazin est ce que c'est le même sentiment
que vous auriez vous sur votre commune
que finalement derrière l'idée reçue
l'emploi c'est pas forcément une
catastrophe dans les zones rurales
c'est à dire que je crois qu'au niveau
de la rue réalité ça dépend de la une
inégalité géographique en fait c'est à
dire qu' il ya des villages qui sont
mieux placés que d'autres et il ya des
villages qui sont pas très loin de
l'agglomération pas très loin de grandes
villes qui n'ont pas de problèmes au
niveau de l'emploi
c'est un petit peu mon cas avant l'avion
n'est pas très loin de joigny on n'est
pas très loin de me gêne pas très loin
d'auxerre donc il est par contre je
connais d'autres villages qui dès qu'on
est à 30 ou 40 km où là il ya un vrai
problème
un vrai problème d'emploi
et c'est la difficulté moi je trouve que
il ya quand même plus d'emplois
aujourd'hui qu'il y a quelques années
c'est exactement le même ressenti que
j'ai parlé de localisation epervans ces
10-15 km de chalon sur saône donc dit
qu'il en est justement la bonne
localisation pour que les gens qui
vivent à epervans puisse travailler sur
cette zone là mais certainement que 50
pour cent soixante pour cent des
personnes qui travaillent et elles
peuvent enfin qui sont travailleurs
serez perdants ont travaillé sur chalon
sur saône dans d'ailleurs là la plus
grande zone d'activité entre paris et
lyon
donc il tout à fait normal que autour
d'epervans légal attraction de chalon et
puis notre côté aussi à l'attraction de
l'autre côté de la bresse vers louhans
surtout les travaux maraîchers et
travaux de la campagne donc on a à la
fois ce sentiment d'un langue de travail
qui est exact est à la fois des pénuries
lorsqu'on en parle aux entrepreneurs des
pénuries sur des personnes qui a pas de
travail et d'apporter un service et des
compétences donc vous vous ressentez
cette différence entre les deux c'est
intéressant cette idée de ressentis
parce qu'effectivement en préparant
cette émission nous on s'est dit c'est
ce qui ressort on l'entend dans le grand
débat actuel d'un monde rural qui se
sent moins bien lotis que les métropoles
donc on s'est dit ça veut dire que pour
l'emploi c'est la même chose
c'est ce que vous évoquez juste avant
mahfoud nahnah oui ça c'est vraiment ce
décalage est donc celle ressentie des
mères mais pour pourquoi de votre point
de vue il ya chez les gens qui vivent à
la campagne cette impression que c'est
beaucoup moins bien que ce que vous
dites sur les chiffres les chiffres que
vous décrivez parce que dans la vie de
tous les jours on ne dit pas de la même
façon parce que dans la vie de tous les
jours il n'y a pas les mêmes avantages
et qu'il faut obligatoirement faire un
déplacement pour faire quelque chose
c'est à dire que pour aller chez le
médecin faut se déplacer pour aller
acheter quelque chose il faut se
déplacer pour aller pour ses loisirs il
faut se déplacer ce qui n'est pas le cas
dans une grande ville et donc
obligatoirement il ya des il ya moins de
revenus mais il ya des dépenses connexes
en plus pour avoir les mêmes les mêmes
les mêmes choses et donc quand on a
moins de revenus et des dépenses
connexes en plus et ben oui les
tourments ses lauriers le clash
d'ailleurs un fabien bazin l'exode rural
les années 60 quand on en parle vous
dit régulièrement mais en fait les gens
reviennent reviennent vers les campagnes
mais ils reviennent pourquoi vers les
campagnes les gens parce qu'ils n'ont
pas assez de sous pour vivre dans les
grandes métropoles
ils n'ont pas les moyens d'y vivre et
ils vont chercher une vie moins chère ou
parce qu'ils vont chercher un confort de
vie ou est-ce que c'est pas les mêmes
personnes les deux c'est à dire que
clairement il ya des gens qui sont
aujourd'hui mis dehors des métropoles ou
qu'elle moi j'suis assez radical je
pense que la vie en métropole c'est pas
l'avis de l'avenir on essaie aujourd'hui
invivable de mon point de vue et puis
effectivement selon lui ai alors dit non
pour connaître un peu les métropoles
j'en suis vraiment persuadé je pense que
ça ne s'arrangera pas oui évidemment les
gens sont poussés hors des grandes
villes pour aller vers la campagne parce
que c'est moins cher d'une part et
d'autre part il ya une envie un désir de
campagne a eu un sondage les collègues
doivent s'en souvenir
l été dernier où 85 % des français
disaient que la vie rêvée allait à la
campagne et on sait aujourd'hui c'est
mesurer régulièrement par les instituts
de sondage que 14 15% des citadins ont
aujourd'hui un projet de vie à la
campagne car ils ont passé un premier
coup de fil pour envisager une
installation et c'est un mail and pas
avec leur emploi ces gens là n'ont pas
forcément dire qu'il faut que le maire
que vous êtes
quoique encore une fois quoique
aujourd'hui la question du télétravail
est totalement centrale chez nous on a
un centre de télétravail qui est rempli
à moitié 8 et les travailleurs sur
quinze bureaux qui sont aujourd'hui
disponibles
on sait qu'on va déployer les outils
d'un meilleur accès internet dans les
deux ou trois ans qui viennent c'est
parti dans la nièvre c'est parti dans
l'yonne c'est parti en saône et loire
on sait enfin par ailleurs
qu'aujourd'hui mes chiffres datent un
peu il ya 7 % le télétravailleur en
france 13% au niveau de l'union
européenne et toutes les études
sérieuses nous disent 20% de
télétravailleurs dans idées dans dix ans
le salarié français en télétravail
donc c'est évidemment une opportunité
pour la campagne mais c'est pas la seule
il ya aujourd'hui des projets
d'implantation
un outil là qui existent aujourd'hui à
montreuil qui vient d'ouvrir à marseille
à nantes et à grenoble et qui veut venir
s'installer chez moi alors mon tour de
nouveaux métiers c'est idyllique ce que
décrit en entendant fabien bazin et
michou ça al'air idyllique cette idée
des urbains qui veulent revenir vous
vous le vivez vous le sentez comme ça
aussi
pas du tout pas du tout parce que je
pense à un moment il faut quand même se
rendre compte dans ses rangs deux
réalités sur l'activité économique en
milieu rural d'ailleurs on le voit bien
qu est ce qui reste comme activité
réellement hormis l'artisanat le
commerce les pme des grandes usines ont
pratiquement disparu ou très bon
placement pour disparition du milieu
rural pour différentes raisons dont on
pourrait discuter plus tard qu'ils sont
structurels à allah à la métropolisation
de notre pays
mais qu'est ce que je remarque sur le
terrain c'est que la plupart des
entreprises artisanales des entreprises
commerciales des petites entreprises ont
du mal à être remise par leur patron
lorsqu'ils arrivent à la retraite
les raisons de celle là son double la
première c'est des raisons d'immobilier
c'est à dire ces artisans qui sont
créées dans les années 70 évoquer thaler
ont créé leur atelier à côté de la
maison et au moment où ils vont devoir
céder ils peuvent pas céder l'atelier
passion et c'est de la maison ça paraît
un peu anecdotique mais c'est une
réalité
la deuxième saut j'ai beaucoup plus
grave c'est qu'en fait la formation
professionnelle elles n'existent
pratiquement plus en milieu rural disons
les choses telles qu'elles sont elle
n'existe plus et d'ailleurs c'est un des
problèmes comme a été évoquée par
monsieur bazin tout à l'heure c'est con
à un plafond de verre du chômage qui est
autour de 9%
pourquoi parce qu'essentiellement il ya
un problème de formation professionnelle
et on le retrouve encore plus 100
millions sera le dire que dans le monde
rural ce parce qu'on a
on entend beaucoup dans le reste du pays
c'est à dire qu'il ya aussi un volant
d'emploi qu'on n'arrive pas à pourvoir
il ya aussi ces entreprises qui ne
trouvent pas de salarié absolument
complément oui complètement
je vois dans le diane beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprise il ya eu de gros
investissements cotés faire 2018
beaucoup de chefs d'entreprises
cherchent du monde et ne trouve pas
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure et
c'est une réalité
l'autre réalité je vais dans ma
communauté de communes ont cherché une
femme de ménage à mi temps trois
personnes ont répondu deux personnes se
sont présentées donc ça veut ça veut
bien dire quand même et c'est pas et
c'est une réalité
c'est une réalité alors une fois qu'on a
dit ça on essaie de comprendre pourquoi
de votre point de vue ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'il ya pas tant de gens
que ça qui on est dans le grand débat là
en ce moment donc faut dire les choses
qui veulent travailler ou qui a que vous
payez pas assez ou qu' il faut prendre
sa voiture c'est des gens qui sont loin
qu'ils doivent relever c'est quoi les
les facteurs min et est ce que c'est des
facteurs spécifiques au monde rural
alors l'un des problèmes je crois que
c'est l'histoire de la voiture et
l'histoire du déplacement ne serait ce
que faire 15 ou 20 km pour aller
travailler avec une voiture c'est pas
toujours évident et il vous avez un tas
de personnes qui n'ont pas de voiture et
qui n'ont pas de moyen de locomotion
cc c'est une réalité dans une réalité
d'un monde rural et d'ailleurs je dois
vous dire que par rapport à ce que
disait mon collègue je suis complètement
d'accord avec lui avec un petit point
c'est que si on n'a pas de résoudre si
aujourd'hui travailler chez soi à
domicile c'est possible il ya des
entreprises qui proposent mais avec on a
obligé d'aller au moins trois fois par
semaine travailler dans l'entreprise
et s'il n'y a pas de moyen de transport
il ya un vrai problème et je vois que
quand on n'a pas de problème au niveau
des transports au niveau quand il ya des
trains qui qui roulait qu'on n'est pas
loin de grandes villes et ses bains
obligatoirement il ya du travail à
possible d'aller la chercher du travail
etc le problème c'est quand on est plus
loin en cassant heureusement la vie à ce
que je voulais vous demander qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce qu'on n'a pas et qu'il
faudrait pour que les choses se passent
mieux dans le monde
je voulais rebondir sur une deuxième
chose d'ailleurs pourquoi finalement on
a parfois du mal à trouver dans des
métiers basique c'est pas péjoratif des
gens pour travailler il faut quand même
appeler un chat un chat
lorsque il est aussi simple de gagner le
même salaire à la maison qu'en allant
travailler
eh ben ça donne pas envie d'aller
travailler mais ce n'est pas une
critique vis-à-vis des travailleurs
c'est une critique aujourd'hui sur le
niveau de rémunération qui à mon sens
est trop bas parce que les charges
sociales sont trop élevés ça sert à rien
de mettre en route des usines à gaz
comme on a vu sur le cic et tous ces
trucs là
besson les charges sociales augmentons
les salaires qui permettra à ce moment
là d'augmenter le pouvoir d'achat et
pour les industriels de vendre leurs
produits moins chers
la mécanique est simple je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les gens qui
travailleraient serait mieux payés que
ceux qui restent à la maison on aurait
moins de problèmes mais ça c'est très
franchement c'est valable
wahou ville et en campagne après les
jeux de philosophie bon très bien moi
sur les deux points que vous soulevez la
transmission de l'entreprise artisanale
qui est continue à la maison c'est une
responsabilité locale
chez nous on a fait ça par exempe
récemment avec une menuiserie donc là
c'est le boulot du maire dans ce cas là
c'est le boulot du maire a bien sûr dire
de plus en plus de boulot de travail
pour faire pour créer de l'emploi et
voilà s'étonner c'est la question que
j'allais vous posez et au niveau local
sajoo l'exemple concret c'est ça
bâtiment relais c'est à dire que la
communauté de communes construit le
bâtiment installe le menuisier le ptit
jeune il tourne comme comme il veut la
mobilité c'est la même chose chez moi on
a aujourd'hui quatre minibus une voiture
qu'on met un con mais en prêt justement
gratuitement justement pour les gens
donc privés de moyens on nous laisse sur
notre thème dans le jeu revient pour qui
est de l'emploi dans le monde rural
il faut que les mères travaillent bien
sûr mais évidemment il ya un enjeu local
de toute façon il faut se le dire
aujourd'hui on ne connaît pas 10% des
métiers qui vont et de 50% mais métiers
qui vont exister dans dix ans bon on est
face au défi du vieillissement c'est on
nous dit que
en l'être humain qui va vivre cinq cent
mille ans aurait déjà nés sur la planète
peu importe ce soit vrai ou pas mais ces
fameux métiers de l'accompagnement des
anciens dont on nous promet depuis des
années les l'explosion elle est en train
d'arriver
j'allais dire de manière naturelle
puisque les les gens qui lisent très
vieux sont de plus en plus nombreux et
qu'on a besoin aujourd'hui d'inventer la
maison de retraite du futur comme il
faut inventer les villages du futur dire
qu'aujourd'hui un village qui se
plongent dans la ruralité moderne
c'est un village qui finalement dit il
est à noter vous faites vos grands
discours nous on est les demain les deux
pieds dans la gadoue et on cherche des
solutions concrètes et opérante sur la
question de l'emploi comme sur la
question est grand temps que les maires
en première ligne oui comme on le voit
ces derniers temps alors il ya faire ce
que ce que disait fabien bazin mahfoud a
marre il ya aussi il faut que les
villages il soit beau qui soit propre
qu'il soit relié avec eux du haut débit
il faut tout ça aussi pour que les
entreprises soient là ou qu'elle reste
ou que il ya tout ça qu'il faut dans
laquelle je voudrais revenir sur sur des
discussions parce que si on avait la
possibilité de faire tout ça et si on en
avait le pouvoir et les moyens
financiers
ça serait fabuleux faux nom alors c'est
à dire qu'il ya plus de ya plus de
problème d'emploi dans votre commune
et lorsque les communes qui sont à côté
de vous ou alors ça voudrait dire que
les maires ils sont pas bons c'est ce
que en fait ça voudrait dire ça en
réalité non non je suis désolé quand
vous voyez que les zrr
1 les zones de revitalisation rurale par
exemple ça a évolué ça changeait et c
est que dans un village x qui est juste
là ils sont en zrr et donc quand une
entreprise s'installe cas là pas
d'impôts etc avec le village qui est
juste à côté lui la des impôts etc etc
une entreprise va plus s'installer là
que s'installer là donc je veux dire et
ça c'est pas le maire qu'il décide je
suis désolé c'est pas le maire qui
décide ce n'est pas une décision
communale
là c'est une décision nationale et je
crois qu'il faut pas tout mélanger
on peut faire des choses en tant que
maire on peut en faire et c'est vrai
qu'on peut en faire au niveau de
l'artisanat donner quelques avec la
communauté de communes parce qu'il faut
pas oublier que désormais c'est la
communauté de communes qui a la
compétence économique avec la région qui
est un outil les communautés de communes
il faut le dire et le répéter un outil
au service des communes journée d'hier
un peu de ce grand ménage mais bon c'est
nous qui sommes en première ligne c'est
nous qui sommes responsables et c'est
nous qui inventons des solutions
concrètes je vous pose la question sur
les communautés de communes euros 3 et
vous pour y répondre avec michou on
entend en ce moment ces derniers jours
dans le débat qui est dans le débat
actuel que on va dire la création des
communautés de communes ça aussi
éloigner les gens de la prise de
décision et qui a une responsable il ya
eu peut-être une responsabilité dans la
situation actuelle et en même temps vous
me dites oui mais les communautés de
communes c'est le bon échelon pour la
dimension économique est bonne et chalon
pour pour le développement économique
parce qu'elle mutualisation qui se fait
ça c'est sûr la deuxième chose sur le
transfert des compétences qui s'est
passé à champs sur saône ya quelques
années j'étais dans l'opposition et je
me suis complètement opposés au
transfert des compétences pratiquement
totale de toutes les responsabilités et
délégations du maire le maire qui
transfère toutes ces compétences perd
ses pouvoirs perdant ses pouvoirs y perd
son rôle est donc on a déresponsabilisé
et retirer le rôle du maire puisque dans
notre collectivité ne te collectivités
le grand chalon pratiquement toutes les
compétences ont été déléguées au grand
chalon
la petite enfance les personnes âgées
l'eau l'assainissement absolument tout
ça date d'un mandat précédent
l'appliquent aujourd'hui mais en fait ça
tirait lui pouvoir au maire alors que le
dernier échelon à notre dans notre
république qui tient encore une espèce
de système social c'est l'échelon du
maire ne voit bien aujourd'hui macron il
vient monsieur macro monsieur le
président pardon vient à la rescousse en
dit en cherchant l'appui des maires
pourquoi parce que c'est les dernières
personnes qui sont crédibles et qui
semble crédit ça c'est sur la structure
même on est d'accord sur l'action
économique et sur l'entreprise
considérée en même temps que c'est
intéressant d'être d'abord ce
regroupement de communes affirme
absolument donc l'endroit où je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans un grand
bazar
des régions qui sont encore en train de
déballer leurs cartons des communautés
de communes qui n'ont pas de visibilité
sur leur budget enfin je vois bien de
celle de dans celle de lanières qui ne
font pas de développement économique
faut arrêter de raconter des histoires
on fait un peu d'accompagnement
commercial air dialaw commerce et à
l'artisanat
mais l'économie c'est d'abord ça ne se
décrète pas et puis c'est pas
foncièrement une affaire de deux
collectivités
en revanche au niveau communal c'est à
dire en partant du besoin des gens en
imaginant en inventant un nouveau modèle
qui correspond au changement majeur qui
sont qui traversent la société
aujourd'hui on obtient des réponses
évidemment ça règle pas tout la question
de l'emploi bien sûr mais à inventer
localement en fonction de
l'environnement de la façon dont on est
organisé sur une territoire communal où
quelques communes quand une fois les
solutions sont possibles et elles
existent aujourd'hui clairement de façon
générale est ce qu'on peut dire de votre
point de vue que l'état en france n'a
pas fait assez d'efforts pour les zones
rurales
autrement dit est-ce que il faudrait
appréhendé en france les zones rurales
et périurbaines de façon très spécifique
alors on fera un clin d'oeil à fabien
bazin sur son leur projet de bouclier
rural il ya quelques années mais même
sans rentrer dans cette formule as que
de façon générale mahfoud aomar qu'on
n'a pas assez fait c'est éric dillies de
géographe qui dit on a fait beaucoup
pour les banlieues pas beaucoup pour la
france périphérique est ce que c'est
votre avis c'est vraiment mon avis je
crois que c'est pas du tout c'est pas du
tout les mêmes solutions que l'on que
l'on âme en ruralité que par rapport une
métropole et aujourd'hui on a donné la
vraiment la préférence aux métropoles
alors que dans la réalité et on le
disait tout d'art il ya vraiment de
vraies choses à faire et il suffirait
simplement qu'ils aient un élan national
de l'état pour ça et nous on est prêts
derrière les élus on est près derrière
pour nous pour justement à avancer dans
ce domaine il ya les lents mais il ya
aussi bêtement des mesures encore plus
fortes ça veut dire moi je sais pas
certain nombre de garanties à certains
nombres dette supplémentaire il faudrait
aussi aller plus loin on va dire de
façon concrète oui c'est pas des fautes
4 mesure le bouclier rural c'est ça que
ça veut dire
autant d'axés pas rappeler pour ceux qui
ne regardent que il ya une dizaine
d'années arthur dans la nièvre vous
avait théorisé
des d'un bouclier rural qui protégerait
plus le monde rural et qu'il l'aiderait
plus bien sûr au service pour la petite
histoire ce concept est en train de
ressortir depuis quelques jours en plein
milieu du débat des gilet jaune et aussi
pour ça qu'on voulait vous avoir parce
que vous êtes probablement une part de
la réponse à la sphère des gilets jaunes
bouclier rural ces quatre idées simples
un temps d'accès maximum au service
public nul ne peut être à plus de 45
minutes d'une maternité nul ne peut être
à plus de vingt minutes d'un accueil de
médecine générale ça nous fera réouvrir
40 maternité en france c'est pas ça qui
vaille effondré le budget du pays
deuxièmement le très haut débit partout
et pour tous aujourd'hui c'est parti
c'est les collectivités qui porte sa
mais on va faire par exemple dans la
nièvre 60% des foyers de la zone rurale
il faut faire 100% 100% rendre les
collectivités savent pas faire donc on
crée un établissement public national
qui s'appelle france fibre donne même le
nom gratuitement et on lance ce grand
chantier pour le pays troisièmement le
réinvestissement de l'épargné collectée
sur les territoires ruraux sur ces mêmes
territoires ruraux
aujourd'hui moi mon directeur d' agences
de 2,2 dans cette bancaire me dis il ya
80 % de l'épargné collectée sur ton
territoire qui par ailleurs c'est un
scandale absolu aux etats unis ils ont
inventé un système s'appelle la loi sur
le réinvestissement du crédit ça partait
des ghettos noirs américains à l'époque
en trente ans on dément bien 1300
milliards de dollars 1300 milliards de
dollars qui sont réinvestis
lol dans les zones en question donc on
sait le faire on à l'outil juridique et
le quatrième c'est un statut pour les
indépendants parce que on n'exerce pas
de la même manière une activité
commerciale ou artisanale en zone rurale
qu'en zone urbaine et vous avez pas
forcément la même étiquette politique et
la même vision du monde et des choses
qu'est ce que vous en dites de ce que
propose fabien bazin s'est il ya
beaucoup de bon sens dans ce qui est dit
là pour moi le monde rural a été à
l'abandonner de la république fracture
sociale fracture économique sur social
c'était quand même est-ce qu'un
président mais exactement le voit encore
de plus en plus aujourd'hui tous est à
bandeau qui s'est fait la plus dès lors
que l'état à travers ses services quitte
le
milieu rural dès lors qu' il n'y existe
pas le même service dans tous les lieux
de la république il ya des dribbles et
les citoyens qui sont donc des citoyens
mais en même temps vous une
positionnement politique vous fait dire
que l'on ne dépense pas l'argent qu'on
n'a pas donc si on ferme les services
publics c'est qu'on n'a plus assez de
non l'étiquette politique c'est une
chose le bon sens sans est certainement
une autre
moi je me souviens très bien dans un
conseil municipal du 1er conseil
municipal que j'ai tenu une anecdote qui
est très important de semble-t-il
j'étais comme la remarque vous faites
l'hôpital il doit être rentable il y
avait une infirmière dans mon conseil
municipal m a dit eric quand aura besoin
de te faire soigner tu demanderas si
c'est un bon médecin ou tu demanderas le
compte d'exploitation de l'hôpital je me
suis dit je préfère quand même un bon
médecin
il faut savoir exactement il ne faut pas
dépenser de l'argent inutilement et de
mauvaises manières je pourrais vous
trouver des sujets sur lequel nous as
manière d'accord tous les deux mais je
n'en suis même pas certain c'est le
cinquième point que j'ai omis de
communiquer tout à l'heure et bien c'est
la question de la démographie médicale
et on peut pas un moment financer les
études des médecins les payer leurs
salaires c'est ce sont là c'est la
sécurité sociale donc c'est nous qui
payons le salaire aujourd'hui des
médecins sans que il renvoie un peu
l'ascenseur
donc ça veut dire quelque part
interrogée la liberté d'installation des
professionnels de santé d'une part et cc
mais définitivement de fermer les
services dans les hôpitaux de proximité
parce que si vous fermez un service dans
un hôpital de proximité comment vous
faites venir le médecin généraliste qui
a besoin d'être rassuré j'ai eu cette
discussion avec les représentants de la
race je ne dirait pas son nom à qui je
dis mais voulait fermer les urgences de
clamecy très bien mais votre objectif
principal c'est de faire venir des
médecins généralistes vous savez très
bien que si vous fermez les urgences du
même si vous vous réduisez votre
capacité à faire bien mais il me dit oui
le type me dit oui
donc il ya un bazar aujourd'hui qui est
qui et qui d'ailleurs ben largement
idéologique sur des modèles de pensée
qui sont des références aux années 80
qui sont pas du tout en phase avec la
société
on n'est pas dans le nouveau monde on
n'est pas dans le nouveau monde le
nouveau monde il se gagne et c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on impose qu'on décrète
des choses qu'on construit je pense que
ça se construit à partir des terreaux et
un dernier mot parce que justement c'est
trop bavard attend très très facilement
mais pardonnez moi mais en même temps
c'est réglé des problèmes chez moi j'ai
un hôpital neuf de tranquille quatre
millions cinq d'euros d'investissements
trois médecins généralistes deux
praticiens hospitaliers qui
en train d'arriver et on va considérer
pourtant que notre secteur est un
secteur qui est parce que c'est la
campagne il ya forcément pas de réponse
médicale mais c'est faux localement les
maires sont formidables on a tous
construits dans nos coins des solutions
qui sont adaptés et on sait y arriver
simplement n'a pas industrialisés le
modèle je suis pas sûr qu'il le soit
mais faudra voir ce que vous entendez
l'a1 est ce que ça vous ressemble
de bonnes idées mais est ce que la
france elle est prête à changer de
modèle et de faire ça alors ça c'est du
bon sens c'est ce que mon collègue
disait mais à côté de ça il ya les gens
et à la décision des gens c'est à dire
que c'est pas parce qu'il ya internet à
un endroit c'est pas parce qu'il ya ya
le haut débit à un endroit que les
entreprises vont venir s'installer
c'est pas parce que regarder il ya des
tas d'endroits où il ya le haut débit et
et il ya du chômage
donc si je vais vous donner l'exemple de
ma commune ya une dizaine d'années j'ai
installé un petit commerce j'ai voulu
j'ai aidé un stade à petit commerce les
gens n'ont pas été dans le petit
commerce parce qu'on est dans le
périurbain et ils avaient tous en
supermarché faire les cruz le petit
commerce il a pas tenu j'ai une commune
à côté de moi qui ai installé un petit
peu mieux dire quoi ça veut dire que
c'était un modèle ancien se dire pour ma
commune il me faut un petit commerce
sinon la commune fonctionnera qu'il faut
peut-être penser autrement il faut
penser autrement justement vous savez
moi je me rends compte que les jeunes on
a deux styles deux jeunes on a des
jeunes qui vont dans des filières ils
sont des vies filière c'est ap plombier
et ses draps et qui restent au pays mais
qui travaille au pays
ensuite je suis maire depuis 2001 et je
m'en suis rendu compte puisque je
commence à être un petit peu avoir un
petit peu d'expérience et puis les peler
les jeunes que j'ai vu je les vois
aujourd'hui travaillent au pays et puis
je vois tous les autres qui ont fait des
études qui sont partis dans des grandes
écoles et caetera et on les voit plus
ils sont partis eux alors est la seule
chance qu'on a c'est peut-être de les
faire revenir à un moment à un moment
ensuite en fin de carrière de le faire
revenir mais troud ils n'auront pas ils
n'ont pas de boulot dans ce qu'ils ont
fait ou dans le dans le pays voilà
localement c'est ça la difficulté
une partie est là et travaille au pays
c'est le sujet de l'émission et une
partie 120 et s'en va pas simplement
france j'en connais beaucoup qui sont
partis à l'étranger vraiment beaucoup
qui sont partis à l'étranger
donc il faut aussi que l'on se lamente
pas sans arrêt et que deux nous mêmes de
nous mêmes le français il
change un petit peu dans sa tête et qui
se disent il faut qu'on prenne les
choses à bras le corps il faut qu'on
avance
il ya des petites choses qui peuvent se
modifier dans notre tête dans notre
cerveau qui nous feront le déclic
certainement dans les changements parce
qu'il nous reste plus beaucoup de temps
et c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
on vous avait proposé de venir fabien
bazin
quand on disait penser autrement par
rapport à ce qu'on faisait d'habitude
c'est à dire faire venir des entreprises
ou pas vous êtes aussi au travail sur
l'opération territoire 0 chômeurs de
longue durée qui a été lancée par
l'ancien député de côte-d'or laurent
grandguillaume lie à prémery où ça
fonctionne vous nous dites en quelques
mots pour ceux qui nous regardent
quel est le principe et puis on verra si
c'est peut-être aussi un modèle
intéressant pour le monde rural
quand on parlait tout à l'heure
d'employabilité de d'emplois non pourvus
ok donc territoire 0 chômeurs longue
durée c'est l'idée d'activer ce qu'on
appelle les dépenses de l'assurance
chômage c'est à dire qu'un chômeur de
longue durée aujourd'hui coûte entre
guillemets entre 18000 et 20000 euros
versés par l'état ou en impôts en impôts
non payés vont récupérer cette somme il
manque 30 % pour construire un smic
on nous dit très vite passé ont fait
monter les enfants terminent bloqué à
valence s'est désolé sur la bbc mais en
tout cas c'est une autre façon de lutter
contre le chômage de longue durée
on n'avait pas tout essayé avec
territoire zéro chômeur on a une réalité
acte à prémery ses 90 cdi qui ont été
signées à ce jour monsieur vous vous
arrêtez je suis désolé mais on est pris
par le temps merci à tous les trois
jours dimanche au revoir